was war die peinliche story dear
zusammen erlebt hat wir kamen vom
alljährlichen nordseeurlaub weiter auf
dem festland und sebastian hat so von
hinten so eine person angesprungen und
umarmen bei der jacke in der gleichen
farbe wie meine jacke abgelegt aber eine
komplett fremde frau die auch schon 334
war herzlich kommt sondern wie die leute
das glaubt mir richtig richtig geil wird
man sogar in frage gestellt ist mir
peinlich extreme privat und auch ein
paar ganz normale fragen gestellt aber
ich hätte die frage heute nicht selbst
beantworten denn ihr habt dem titel
gelesen meine freunde beantworten eure
fragen über mich in diesem video und ich
werde live drauf gehen und gucken was
sie sagen nur selbst bedeute aber ich
finde die idee ultra stabil was über
mich ich dann was irgendwie haben alle
zusammen spaß und wer noch ein rädchen
dazu sogar die drei jungs der euro frage
habe ich beantworte werden sind lukas
ein freund von mir
dave ein anderer freund und mein kleiner
bruder max der auch ja wie mein bester
freund ist
erste frage was ist sebastians
lieblingsmusik aber das ist im moment
auf jeden fall countrymusik und
herrliche musik egal wohin wir fahren
zum beiden gehören
sebastians musikvielfalt reicht von
country über schlager zu deutsch das
tier entdeckt wirklich jedes musikgenre
ab ich würde sagen dass country momentan
sorgen um einzigen ist auch das ist wahr
leute guckt also du kannst ja eben schon
gesagt es ist es ist momentan kann
natürlich groß ich höre aktuell aber
auch blumen was irgendwie so elektro
komposition ist oder so dadurch
zwischendrin school lab deutschrap ist
es wirklich krank wenn ich über die
letzten jahre den schwerpunkt nennen
müsste würde ich sagen wenn es hipper
sebastian gerne country aber getrotzt
und sagen okay okay stimmt auch das
stimmt leute hat sich die pop somit der
rote faden so ich habe auch wirklich in
fast jeder situation im leben
irgendeinem eppelein immer im kopf wenn
ich alles so gut könnte wir appliance
erinnern dann wäre mein leben deutlich
besser nächste frage was kann sebastian
am besten was kannst kann sie was von
sebastian am besten dass wir uns
ausdenken sagt marschall einfach der
redner safe eingehen
aber klar ist dass gilde der joker was
laberst du ich dachte mich mache video
in dem meine freunde fragen mich
beantworte ich dachte so mega ziemlich
coole video idee was kommt meine besten
fähigkeiten sind schon bei essen und
weiber klären was immer wenn irgendwie
bei mir rest übrig bleiben oder sonst
irgendwas um den ersten neben sebastian
ist immer das gleiche und silvester hat
auch immer hunger lotte es setzt euch
nicht mit mir am tisch und ist mit mir
weil wenn ich hunger habe und meinen
ersten aufgegessen ist und ihr erst noch
essen was sehr wahrscheinlich jetzt
schnell esse dann wird mein blick auf
ihr essen danach ungefähr so sein ich
war das meistens ja nicht mit absicht
aber ungefähr zehn sekunden ist die
person sagt du bist was abhaben
sebastian
größte stärke oder das was er am besten
kann ist langfristig sachen
durchzuziehen ist er sein ziel erreicht
hat sah es sport oder youtube oder ganz
viele andere dinge irgendwie einfach
seine ziele langfristig durchzuziehen
seine klingt aber gut dass das finde ich
gut das finde ich gut luca luka was ist
eine entschuldigung lege mein bester
skill ist essen und wein erklären sich
aus wie ein fetter hugh hefner will für
fragen was war die peinliche story dear
zusammen erlebt habt die peinlichste was
jemand erlebt habe in triest wir waren
mit ein paar kumpels zusammen im italien
urlaub und da waren wir gemeinsam in
einem garten was da genau passiert ist
kann ich leider nicht erzählen also geht
wirklich überhaupt nicht aber das war
die peinliche situation die ich mit
sebastian zusammen erlebt habe es war
wirklich geisteskranke habe ich das
glaube ich dass zu krass verdrängt ich
erinnere mich gerade gar nicht so genau
was er meint damit in triest wir haben
so weit haben sie und jungs tritt man
nach triest gemacht aber in welchem
garten omeyer
das kann ich das gar nicht mehr so weit
sein bruder bin gibt es natürlich einige
effekte vom alljährlichen nordsee urlaub
oder auf dem festland wasser gelassen
und sebastian abzug von hinten so eine
person angesprungen und zum abend bei
der jacke in der gleichen farbe wie
meine jacke absolut dafür aber eine
komplett trennende frau wie auch schon
30 uhr öffnungen
30 war das am besten leben wer einmal so
fangen gespielt an dem bahnhof kam aus
dem urlaub zurück max hatte eine rote
jacke an
man hat immer so gejagt und dann so hab
dich erwischt so so angesprungen und so
festgehalten und dann springe ich
einfach diese person mit einer roten
jacke an und sage jetzt habe ich dich
persönlich um frau mit 45 so muss los wo
das nächste frage was war der lustigste
moment den wir mit sebastian hat es und
zwar mir zusammen mit max jana jakob
möglicherweise freund jan bei einem
festival und zwar beim splash dazu gilt
wurde
wir waren irgendwie im hotelzimmer also
zusammen und jan kam rein und hatte eine
diagnostik aber nicht die besten
weil das war es was dieser moment war
wirklich zu krank war
das war einer dieser legendären momente
2017 hier auch im splash alle mit dieser
runde
maxian paar freunde und dann dann ist
das hier passiert zwar wirklich zu
glauben
wir hatten ich habe eine idee und ist
das irgendwie so um ihn geworden dass
wir gesagt haben lässt man besser nicht
machen weil es die von jan hat halt so
die idee vorgeschlagen wir haben gerne
ab und zu mal so gewiss das war wirklich
eine gute idee
es war eine gute idee es war still im
raum es war stelle und da hat einer
gesagt die gute idee aber dass man nicht
machen aber so aufräumt aber so dass
dieser auf die idee von mir kam und dann
ist das hier entstanden leute gebt euch
diese videos
in asien pazifik japan nase und blut
verlage hatte war zugleich der nächste
frage welches war die peinlichste auf
story von sebastian ich weiß dass ein
video von sebastian existiert bei dem
wir feiern bahn in so einem standard
club von und ich meine sogar schwer
wehren kann rein gewesen was in köln ja
einmal absoluter ausnahmezustand ist wie
das mega betrunken und ich meine dass
sebastian also extra in die menge
geschüttet hat was halt krank
denn eigentlich ist das ist irgendein
video existiere
das ist fast richtig 90 prozent aber
durch ganz wie weit kann weil das tier
müsste man karneval hat keinen kopf
bewahren kann aber leute und an karneval
geht man in köln vorab so wenn ihr in
köln nicht wollen dann können sie
nachvollziehen aber köln ist
ausnahmezustand an karneval und ja wie
weit die jungs auch beim feiern nicht
zum start schon wenn ihr wisst dann habe
ich halt ein paar reihen für die für die
toten brüder haus kostet kennt ihr das
nicht so ein vorhaben ist einfach so ein
schluck aber nicht auf leute waren auf
den boden so nicht
ich habe sebastian und max in köln
abgeholt und an dem tag war karneval
erhalten aber am nächsten tag nach new
york wo gott das mannschaftlich abgeholt
und sebastian lag einfach weil max auf
dem auf den küchentisch warm schlafen
und war absolut betrunken ein bild von
mir
es war aber auch wirklich die beste idee
die man haben kann am tag bevor man nach
new york fliegt noch karneval zu feiern
natürlich ist die ganze sache nach
hinten losgegangen aber leute ich hab es
gut gehandelt max hat ja so eine kleine
an richtigkeit erfolgt dass sein wie es
also hat so eine große küche und dann in
der mitte so eine insel die ist ungefähr
hüfthoch der beste leben ich einfach mit
der hüfte an diese
diese rand gestellt und den oberkörper
einfach drauf geklappt also da
geschlafen warum nicht exakt nächste
frage mit wie vielen jahren hatte er das
erste mal sy iks würde sagen 1516 16 mit
ich glaube und als irgendwie keinen
stresstest vorstellen
ich denke so mit 17 oder 18 wurden so
die antwort gespannt ich glaube ich
glaube ich glaube egal wie egal leute
das jetzt ein persönliches video cloud
man sich einfach mal mega offen wieder
offen ich weiß noch nicht ob es die
beste idee ist aber es war so hinter 217
habe ich kann nur mutmaßen
deswegen lasse ich die frage
unbeantwortet ok nächste frage was hast
sebastian am meisten dass also ein
bisschen unstrukturiert manchmal ist und
sachen immer gerne auf den nächsten tag
verschiebt oder wenn ihm sachen
vorgeschrieben werden oder wenn es
gefestigte gefestigte dinge in der
gesellschaft gibt es ein
vorgeschriebener vorgeschriebener
musikstil für die momentane jugend und
seinen stil daraus ausbricht dann wird
euch sachen über die iren auf instagram
verfolgt über die er sich extrem
aufregen kann
new york new york new york also sowieso
herdentrieb so die wissen was mein gott
wenn ich herrn trieb sage so dass alle
leute immer eine sache machen müssen so
auch mein gott das ist 2020 alle müssten
planung pop smoke hören oder so dass
gegen popmog aber kopien fucking kommen
wenn ich kannte ja so diese wafer auf
jeden fall ein letzter zeit nicht
mitbekommen dass ihr was man sich stark
über leute
so ein künstliches bild von sich
aufrecht erhalten nach dem motto mein
gott ihr macht euch gar kein bild ich
wie gesagt ich bin mache ich eine weile
youtube machen weil instagram wie viele
leute nicht aus dieser branche
kennengelernt habe sei es youtube sei es
in stalker die einfach so krass anders
sind aber im negativen sinne bezeichnet
die vermitteln den leuten ein bild von
sich dass sie einfach nicht sind sehen
aus wie ein topmodel oder was auch immer
aber sind es im echten leben einfach
nicht so dass ich mal so wie gehabt
fragte warum fragst du die leute so ich
meine es ist klar dass man auf install
seine beste seite zeitung hat er war
aber manche leute zeigen ihre beste
seite die zeigen eine andere person
glaubt mir und das finde ich einfach und
ehrlich den vollen gegenüber und das
baut druck auf die auch weil die auch so
sein wollen nordkueste frage und ich
finde auch eine sehr gute frage was
zeigt der in den videos nicht sein thema
ich glaube alkohol sieht man relativ
wenig in seinen videos das ist natürlich
sehr gut denn so erschafft er kein
falsches bild für jugendliche oder
heranwachsende oder hört ja so viel zu
dem tier war einfach heute also weil
diese stories gelegt gutes vorbild aber
ja eigentlich gut dass wirklich gutes
vorbild werde zwar in diesen geile
erinnerungen sebastian hat seine
angewohnheit dass immer wenn er sich an
verrechnet oder
weißt du sich auf die zunge und steckte
sogar und das macht er mittlerweile wenn
er ein paar jungs pause wieder diese
wenn er seine schuhe anzieht wenn du am
kochen ist wenn möglich zu jeder
lebenssituation wo sich irgendwie ein
wenig anstrengung bedarf strecke gezogen
ich habe auch so klug agiert also us
dollar
ich hab mir so richtig gebaut also etwas
so aufgenommen und so als wir haben
heute aber es ist halt so da hab ich
mein vater mein vater macht das eins zu
eins so habe ich von ihm so so einfach
man muss ja konstatieren einfach zunge
raus das gleichgewicht und gesicht
verziehen
ja genau leute was für ein geiles video
auch noch so viele geile antworten von
jungs bekommen die aber einfach zu lang
sind um diese video herein zu machen
jungs ich danke euch vielmals sofern die
jungs eine öffentliche auftritt haben
sind die und in der beschreibung
verlinken heute geil ist geil ist geil
is bio für solche videos mache ich mit
typisch feier ist hat richtig spaß
gemacht hier gibt's einfach ich
vorgeschlagen habe ich bilder daraus
macht gut bleibt stabil
ciao